[MUSIC PLAYING]
RAFAEL SANCHEZ: My
name is Rafael Sanchez.
I am Customer Engineer
of Google Cloud.
I am based in Madrid.
And I'm on here on the stage
with Jose Antonio Marcos, who
is the Head of the Smart
Maintenance Engineer in Talgo.
We're going to talk to
you today about what
we think this is a very
interesting IoT use case.
Because we are going to be
talking about high speed
trains operating
at 300 kilometers
per hour, around
200 miles per hour,
in the desert of Saudi Arabia.
So you can imagine that they
have very strict weather
conditions there.
And these trains operating
at 300 kilometers per hour
are going to send--
or are sending, actually, up
to 2,000 signals per second
to the cloud for processing
for predictive maintenance.
So this is what we are
going to talk today.
So, this case study is actually
a study around asset tracking
and asset management.
And before describing
the case itself,
I would like to start by
making some definitions, OK?
Knowing that no
definition is perfect,
I would like to
start by defining
what is an asset, what
is asset tracking,
and what is asset
management, OK,
in order to understand
the scope of what we
are going to talk to you today.
So, let me start off with
a definition of an asset.
An asset is a useful or valuable
thing or person, generally
owned by a person or
enterprise, available to perform
some utility.
Asset tracking is basically
around two concepts
of these centers.
Asset tracking is around
real-time awareness
of a valuable thing
that we own, OK?
So we'll have
some-- for example,
in the train we'll have some
subsystems that we would like
to measure, something
valuable for us,
something valuable for Talgo.
And we would like to make
some real-time awareness
of that particular information.
So, asset tracking is around
understanding these business
questions that you
see on this slide.
So, where is my assets?
So, where is the
train, for example,
or where are certain
parts of the train?
How does it get to go
to the destination?
Or what is the
current condition, OK?
An asset, in the
context of Talgo,
is not the train as a whole.
It's a series of subsystems
that exist in the train
and that we would like
to make tracking of, OK?
So, and what is
asset management?
Asset management is
around performance,
is around understanding
and managing
how an asset is being used.
So we are trying to answer the
business question here, like,
if some parts of the
train are likely to fail,
how efficiently it's being used,
or how a particular asset is
performing.
So the question is,
how do we answer
those particular
business questions?
So, how do we get
the information
that we need from these
business questions?
So, what we think
is that we will
be able to answer these
business questions if we
collect the right amount of
data related to time and space.
So if we are able to
have tools in order
to collect the right information
related with time and space,
we should be able to answer the
business question before, OK?
So regarding the-- so,
actually, the problem
of answering those
business question--
we have turned that particular
problem into a situation where
we need to collect the
right amount of information,
the right amount of data,
related to time and space.
So in our timing, we
are interested basically
in there periods of time.
We get interested in the now,
in the current situation, OK?
And this is basically the
real-time collection of data--
data which can be associated
with temperature, either
the outside temperature or the
temperature of the differential
system in the train,
or can be, for example,
voltage, or it
can be hydraulics,
or can be some particular
things in the train
that we would like to measure.
Past information is
just the information
we have already collected, OK?
So for example, in the
train-- this is, by the way,
the train which is in
production in Talgo.
This is the line between
Medina and Mecca.
So this is actually
the case study
we are talking about here.
So in a train within
that route, we
are collecting
information in the past.
And we are storing
that information, OK?
So this is the past period
that we are also interested.
And so, basically,
the past periods
is just the information
and real-time information
that we have collected
in the past, OK?
So, we can do these basically
with the same tools.
And the future is
not information
that we are
collecting, of course.
Those data does not exist.
The future is basically
information that we predict.
And we predict using machine
learning technologies.
And we predict using
machine learning similarly
with the data that we
have already collected.
We have data we have
collected in the past
and with the real-time
data we are collecting.
So these are the
three periods of time,
and we need to
collect information.
And these are on timing.
And what about the space?
In the space, there has been
a change over the last years
related to space.
Basically, there has to be
a shift from location data
into location intelligence.
In the past, location was just
to put a spot on a map, OK?
So to put some
train, in this case,
in a particular map-- when
we moved to digital maps,
it was basically that.
But in the last
years, there has been
a shift from location data
to location intelligence
where we add context
information around the location.
So the location is not just
the latitude and the longitude
where the train is.
It's an amount of information
around that particular location
where we can get some
intelligence from.
So, in order to do this, in
order to collect information
from time, in order to collect
information from space,
we need to have the right tools.
We need to have the
right tools in the cloud.
And Google Cloud has
very interesting tools
in order to collect information
relating to time and space.
For space, we have our Google
Maps platform for enterprises,
OK?
And for timing, we have a
series of processing data tools
that allow us also to
collect information regarding
the time-- real-time awareness,
past information, et cetera.
We can find these tools
as separate products--
tools for ingestion,
tools for processing,
tools for visualization.
But also in Google Cloud-- just
to give you an example of some
of the problems that we have--
we have also problems that
combine time and space
information into just one.
And I would like to show
you just one of it, which
is the BigQuery GIS.
I should point out
you know BigQuery.
BigQuery's our data
warehouse product.
It's a serverless platform to
make queries over large data
sets at very competitive costs.
It's a serverless platform.
And we have introduced a new
feature, which basically allow
us to visualize
latitude and longitude
information within BigQuery.
So we can build SQL queries
with geographical information
inside.
And we can visualize that
information dynamically
in the broadest sense, OK?
So, this is a sample of
a product that combines
timing and space information.
And Talgo is actually using some
of the Google Cloud products
that allow to collect the timing
and space information, OK?
And this is the use
case we are going
to talk to you about today.
This case study was
published one month ago.
You can access to the
case study in that URL--
cloud.google.com
/customers/talgo/,
where we described the
case study in detail,
and actually with some
quotes from Jose Antonio.
And, well, we described
all the technology
that we were using in that.
But I cannot think of a better
person to tell us more about
Talgo and to tell us more about
why Talgo have chosen Google
Cloud than Jose Antonio Marcos,
who will tell us more about
the case study.
JOSE ANTONIO MARCOS
ALBERCA: Thank you, Rafael.
Good afternoon, everyone.
First of all, let me
introduce you to Talgo.
Talgo is a high speed
manufacturing and maintenance
company funded in 1942.
In their early days,
Talgo designed trains
with very innovative
features, which
is the backbone of the company.
Actually, Talgo has
started to build trains--
light, aluminum
trains-- in USA in 1946,
using the aircraft
technology, aluminum,
because that
technology-- it wasn't
that available in Europe.
77 years later, Talgo is
leader with this technology
in different countries.
Nowadays, Talgo is
developing high-speed trains
running about 220 miles per
hour, 350 kilometers per hour.
For example, this is their
new high-speed train in Spain.
This new project
for AVRIL for High
Speed 2 in UK, AVRIL-UK,
and the high-speed train
for Saudi Arabia, which
is the case that I'm going
to present to you afterwards.
Regarding Talgo technology,
the main features
comparing Talgo trends
with the standard ones
are, for example, independent
wheels, natural tilting,
aluminum light cars, lower floor
level, automatic gauge change,
and articulated cars.
As general information, Talgo
main figures are as follows.
Talgo has footprint in 44
countries, more than 4,000
vehicles, 77 years
of experience,
and we are performing more
than 1,000 million kilometers
per year.
So that means four times the
distance between the Earth
to the moon every year,
just to keep in mind.
Now we get into the gates.
Nowadays, high-speed trains'
maintenance operation
is very complex and high tech.
We need to solve different
technology challenges.
For example, safety first, no
questions; very high speed,
more than 220 miles per hour
or 350 kilometers per hour;
reliability, about
1 million miles
between a stop between delays;
availability, 100% the trains
running on the track;
and maintenance intervals
between the stops
every 30,000 miles.
So how to do it?
In order to reach
these challenges,
we had to work with new
maintenance technologies--
for example, CBM,
Condition-Based
Maintenance in
order to anticipate
the failures of
the train that may
result in lack of availability
and reliability of the train.
To apply condition-based
maintenance,
we need to develop algorithms.
These algorithms
need a lot of data
in order to work with
machine learning.
So in order to get
this data, we have
developed a real-time
monitoring system
using Google Cloud
platform that you
are going to see afterwards.
Rafael is going to show you.
So now we get into
this successful case,
monitoring system for Saudi
Arabia high-speed trains.
This project had
several challenges.
For example, extreme
weather condition,
high temperature during
summertime more than 120
degrees Fahrenheit, extreme
weather conditions, sandstorms,
the geography.
Another challenge
was to understand
how to send bigger stream data
from the train to the ground
control.
And we had to decide how to
do it, not for this train,
but for the future trains.
So what were the challenges
that we had to deal with?
We had to deal with data
transmission ingestion
capacity, processing capacity,
and storage capacity--
all of these challenge.
How did we solve it?
We had to sell in from
different options.
On-premise, we need a huge
investment, other cloud
solution, and finally, we
decide to go with Google Cloud.
Why?
Because Google Cloud offered
us different advantages,
for example, unlimited
scalability, connectivity,
massive storage, streaming
data, and machine learning
for predictive maintenance.
How is the process?
The train is sending data
in three different ways,
using a UDP datagrams.
It is streaming data,
live streaming data.
We are sending more than 2,000
signals per second per train.
Also, we are able to
download the whole database
when the train go to the
maintenance facilities
through Wi-Fi.
I'm talking about 2
gigabytes per train per day.
And also, we are sending
the batch alarms.
Every 10 minutes, we are
sending the main alarms
and the main events
from the train.
So once we have the
data in the cloud,
ingest it, and store
it in BigQuery,
we are able to track the
trains you see in Google Maps.
Also, performing in
real-time monitoring.
And we are doing
machine learning
on predictive maintenance
using our application, Talgo
Tesla The acronym of Tesla is
Train Efficient System Logic
Analysis.
So, now we are
going to see a video
with the example
of the application
that we developed
using Google Maps.
So here, we can see the trains--
the location of the trains.
We can find out the problem that
they are sending in real time.
We can select different
data, different parameters,
to understand which is the
problem that the train is
having in order to get
the insight of the data.
So we can choose from different
trains, different countries.
Now we are going
to see an example
with a video of the
application that we
developed using Google Cloud.
This is real-time monitoring.
We are monitoring
different parameters
of the train-- the speed.
And also, we are able
to monitor in real time
every single signals in order
to analyze what is going on
and to improve the availability
and reliability of the train.
OK, so now, Rafael
is going to show you
which is the architecture
of this case.
RAFAEL SANCHEZ: OK,
thank you, Jose Antonio.
So I'm going to show
you now the architecture
which is in production today--
in production today in
the Saudi Arabia line, OK?
So basically, the
architecture that
generate all these
videos and graphs
that we have seen before.
So, I'm going to describe
the three architectures that
are in production today.
One is about
real-time monitoring.
The other one is about
the historical analysis.
And the third one is about
event data management.
So let me start
with the first one.
This is the one about
real-time monitoring
where the trains operating
at 300 kilometers per hour
are sending 2,000 UDP datagrams
per second to the cloud.
So they are sending this by
using GSM-R technology, OK?
So GSM is-- I mean, it's a
public telephony standard.
And there is a variant for
the railways obligation,
which in the GSM-R, actually
the R is for "Railway."
And this is a very well-known
railway standard, OK?
So the GSM-R has
the capabilities,
or has very interesting
capability for somebody
to operate at a
different frequency
band than the public GMS.
So therefore, there
are no interference
with the public GSM technology.
It can also operate with trains
up to 500 kilometers per hour.
So it's good enough for
this particular obligation.
And also, normally, we do
design a high speed line
with GSM-R. You have antennas
all over the lines, which
guarantees you the coverage
even inside the tunnels.
OK?
So that's the reason why the
GSM-R is good enough technology
today for this
particular obligation.
So, we are using GSM-R.
And then over a VPN, OK?
Sorry, over a VPN, we
are sending the signals
to a managed instance group
in Google Cloud Platform.
Actually, we are using an
internal load balancer--
an internal load
balancer here, which
basically balances the traffic
to the different computing
machines.
So after that,
all the traffic is
being sent to our queuing
system to Cloud Pub/Sub.
And then it is going to
AppEngine for processing, OK?
So, we are not using Dataflow
on that particular application.
We are using a Node.js
application built on AppEngine
which is basically
decoding the UDP packets.
And then the packets are going
for visualization in real time
to another AppEngine
application which
is the one that makes
the visualization.
And one interesting
capability is
that we are also
using a database here
in order to store all the
real-time information that we
are receiving, OK?
So while there is here
a real-time path using
a WebSocket that visualizes
directly all the real-time
information into our graph,
we are also storing--
Talgo is also storing--
the historical information
coming from this stream.
So to summarize this
particular architecture,
so we are collecting
the information
using GSM-R with UDP datagrams.
Then this goes to an
outer scalar group
built with an internal load
balancer on a managed instance
group.
Then it goes to Pub/Sub for
collecting all the information,
AppEngine to decode
the UDP datagrams
and extract the useful
information, and finally
another AppEngine application
for visualization.
You may notice that, on this
particular architecture,
there is no Cloud
IoT Core, which
is one of the problems that
normally appears in an IoT
application like this.
And the reason is the following.
When we designed these
particular architectures,
the train were
already built. So you
can imagine that a train
like this takes a lot of time
to redesign and
to remanufacture.
And there is a lot
of security inside.
I mean, you cannot just come
here and put a software there
or a hardware there
because, I mean,
Talgo is making a very strict
moderation process for hardware
and software.
So basically, we didn't
arrive with enough time
in order to install
our Cloud SDK,
uninstall all the MQTT
client on the train
in order to be able to
talk to Cloud IoT Core.
Because Cloud IoT Core, as you
know, requires MQTT or HTTP
and requires also TLS 1.2.
So we could not install all
the right software libraries
in order to deploy
that on the trains.
The future architecture, I
will describe you afterwards.
They are-- we're including
Cloud IoT Core, of course, OK?
So that's the
reason behind that.
Basically, we didn't
have time in order
to install and moderate
all the software
and to pass all of the
moderation tests required
by Talgo.
Because again, as
you can see, this
is a very strict device, OK?
So we need to pass very, very
strict moderation process.
And we cannot just go
and do whatever we want.
So, this is the architecture
about real-time monitoring.
The next architecture is
about historical analysis.
In this case, the information is
sent when the train is stopped.
It's stopped for maintenance.
It's stopped for maintenance
at a Talgo facility, OK?
So the train is stopped.
This happens normally once every
15 days or once every 20 days.
And when that happens, the train
is sending 2 gigabyte files
per day of operation to a local
computer which is installed
on the Talgo facility.
So again, you may ask, why
your local computers here?
The reason is the
same as before.
We didn't have time to
add the necessary software
on the train, our
Cloud SDK, et cetera,
in order to send
the data to GCS.
But in the future
architecture, this is included.
So these files are--
again, these are
SQLite databases,
which are 2 gigabytes
size per day, which
is sent to a local computer.
In this local computer,
we have gsutil installed.
Then the local computer
sends information
to cloud storage in gsutil.
And then when that
happens, there
is a Cloud Function
which is triggered.
And this trigger will launch
a Dataflow pipeline to process
all the SQLite database.
So the SQLite database
go to BigQuery
for storage and visualization
and to an AppEngine
for visualization of
the historical data.
So to summarize, we have Wi-Fi
data when the train is stopped,
which is sent to a local
computer and cloud storage.
Then we are sending it
to a Cloud Function.
And a Cloud Function is
triggered for extraction, then
Dataflow, and then
AppEngine for visualization.
And the third architecture
which is in production in Talgo
is the one about event data
and alarm data collection.
So, this is not in real time
because this is actually
a batch type of
architecture because we are
sending alarms every minute.
And we are sending events
every 10 minutes to the cloud.
So what is an event in
this particular context?
So, an event is triggered where
certain conditions are met.
For example, imagine
that a temperature
is higher than 40 degrees, plus
that the voltage is exceeding
whatever value, plus
the train speed is
at 250 kilometers per hour.
If the three conditions
are met, then an event
is triggered and is
sent to the cloud.
But we are not collecting
events and alarms in real time.
We are collecting events
and alarms in batch mode.
So alarms every minute, and
events every 10 minutes.
So, the way we send this
information is again via GSM-R
using a VPN over TCP to
compute it in machine.
We don't need
autoscaling in this case
because the amount of
traffic is relatively low.
And then this is sent to
cloud storage for storing.
And then this
information is sent--
I mean, there is an application
which is basically collecting
the information
from cloud storage,
and then sent to Pub/Sub,
Cloud Dataflow for processing,
BigQuery, AppEngine, and
finally visualizing here.
The visualization is happening
in a tool called Cassandra,
which, by the way, has nothing
to do with a Cassandra NoSQL
database, OK?
So it's a customized
tool for Talgo.
I mean, the name has
nothing to do with that.
So to summarize, so
the events and alarms
are sent through
GSM-R in batch mode.
This is sent in cloud storage,
and then from cloud storage,
we start all the processing
and visualization
using the standard
pipeline processing
with Dataflow, Pub/Sub, and
BigQuery until visualization.
OK, so until now, I
have described the three
architectures which
are in production today
in the Saudi Arabia line
between Medina and Mecca.
From now on, I am
going to talk to you
about the new architecture
that are going
to be designed for the new
lines that Talgo is going
to employ all over the world.
So this architecture
has been designed,
and has been all right with
them over the last months.
And basically the
general view is this one.
So we have designed this in mind
according to the requirements
that Talgo had.
And Talgo had requirements
not only of data scaling,
of course, because
there are going
to be more and more lines
with this architecture,
and these require quite an
escalation in terms of data.
But also, this has been
designed because there
are other devices where we need
to collect information from,
OK?
So, and these are
not only the trains.
So for example, if
you see here, these
are the structures which are
equipped across the lines, OK?
So these are, like,
the wayside inspections
that are collecting
information from the train
as the train is passing through
this particular structure, OK?
So, these are not
the train itself.
These are devices, OK?
So you can see here devices
that are put in the line
and that they are getting
information from the train.
Also in the train itself, we
are interested in collecting not
only data information itself.
We are also interested in
collecting multimedia files,
for example, images
and also audios.
Because audios are
very interesting
in order to detect
problems in the train, OK?
So if you listen to,
for example, the engine
of the train, you can make
predictive maintenance
according to a particular audio.
So multimedia files are
also very, very interesting.
And the new requirements
include the collection
of this type of information.
So, this new
architecture basically
includes three new elements.
The first element
is Cloud IoT Core.
So Cloud IoT Core now
is going to be included.
And We're going to
use MQTT in order
to send the messages
to the train.
And also, we are going
to use TLS 1.2 in order
to make the transportation.
We are going to add
also some processing
at the Edge, so some
processing in the train itself.
So now, we are going to design
some customized software
in order to be equipped
inside the train,
and also hardware that we are
going to put inside the train
in order to make,
for example, well,
machine learning,
predictive maintenance,
and some other stuff.
And finally, the
third piece we are
going to add to the architecture
is Cloud ML Engine in order
to make all the training that
is required with the data
that we are collecting,
and also to be
able to download all the models
that are training in the cloud
to the devices in
the train itself.
So these are the
three key elements
that are going to be added.
Let me go a little bit
deeper into these two--
into the Cloud IoT Core on the
cloud and the Edge processing.
The Cloud Machine
Learning Engine, I think,
is very well-known
product from Google Cloud.
So I will skip that
in this presentation.
So let me focus on these two.
So, Cloud IoT Core--
I mean, it's a product
that is already GA,
and basically it provides
two capabilities.
It's a message broker for
HTTP and MQTT messages.
It provides also security by
implementing TLS 1.2 mandatory
in all the communications,
and also provides
device management capability.
So somehow, it's an inventory
of all the essentials
and subsystems that are
tracked in the train.
One of the characteristics
of Cloud IoT Core
is that it's
completely serverless
and has a unique
global access point.
So no matter if Talgo is
operating in Saudi Arabia,
in the US, or in
the United Kingdom--
all the information is going
to be sent to the Google Cloud
through the closest data center.
And this is going to
happen automatically
without Talgo intervention.
So this is about
the Cloud IoT Core.
And one of the most
interesting part
is the processing we have
designed for the Edge.
In this slide, that you can
see two parts, one in the left
and one in the right.
The right is just basically
a summary of the cloud
piece for machine learning.
So I am going to skip
this part because it's
more or less
obvious and does not
contain all the details
of the previous slides.
I'm going to focus more
on this particular part--
on the left part,
which is the part
which is going to be
equipped in the train.
So in the train, we
have an Ethernet bus,
which is here, OK?
So this Ethernet
bus is basically
the bus which is collecting all
type of signals in the train.
So it's a very--
I mean, it's a very
important part of the train
because it's collecting
all kind of signals.
Some of these signals
are going to be
sent to the software we
have designed in the Edge,
and are going to be sent through
a path protected by a diode,
OK?
So this diode is going
to prevent the signals
from going from the
software to the bus, OK?
So it will only allow
signals from the Ethernet bus
to our software part.
Then this piece of software is
going to be designed for Talgo.
And it's basically
a software based
on a microservices architecture.
So we are going to design
a container-based solution
for this particular part.
And basically what this
software piece has,
first of all, a interface
software, which is-- this
is not a container.
This is basically,
well, firmware
which is collecting
the information coming
from the Ethernet bus.
And then this is going
to send information
to the container that
will receive the signals.
Then this container
must exist mandatory.
The other container that
must exist also mandatory
is what we call
"Container ZERO," which
is the one which is sending
the information to the cloud--
sending and receiving
information to the cloud.
So this will send all kind of
events, alarms, variables, et
cetera, as well as it will
download any machine learning
models coming from the cloud.
And then optionally,
we should have
one or more extra containers
for different tasks.
For example, we can
have a container
in order to select
the variables that we
are going to send to the cloud.
Or for example, this
container can also
make some machine learning
activities if required.
The design-based
container is basically
a little bit open on
this particular part
because we can design a software
with three or four containers.
But basically the architecture
is based on containers
in order to facilitate
isolation and in order
to facilitate scalability.
So for a high speed
train like this,
security is very important.
I mean, you can imagine that
these trains cannot fail, OK?
So these trains-- everything
must work perfect.
And a containerized
mesh application
fits in this
particular requirement.
So that's the reason why we
have this service architecture
for this particular part.
So this container
solution is going
to be built on a Linux
OS operating system.
And then below that, we
will have the hardware part.
And the hardware part
initially is going
to be designed with a CPU--
I mean, basically with a
CPU, and optionally, we
are going to place-- we are
going to host a space for TPUs.
Because we think
that the use cases
for this particular big
issue may require the TPUs,
especially for the
multimedia processing.
So, that's basically
the design that
is going to implemented
in the train.
So a microservice
architecture built
on software and hardware
that needs to be, of course,
moderated by Talgo.
For the hardware
part, the Edge TPU--
I mean, just for
your information,
we have recently released
through our partner, Coral,
some TPUs already available
in system-on-modules
architectures, OK?
So you can see if you go
to the web page of Coral,
this partner of Google
has released some hardware
cards with TPU inside with
different hardware schemes.
So we can use a
system on module.
And also you can
use PCI accelerators
to replace any card.
So there are different
options to install
this kind of hardware.
So, with this design in mind,
how would the architectures
look like?
So the architecture for
the new speed trains
look like the following.
For historical
analysis, the changes
are that we are
going now to-- well,
we are still using
Wi-Fi in order
to send the historical
databases to the cloud.
You may notice that there is
no local computer anymore, OK?
Because we have installed
the cloud as a gate.
And gsutil in the train.
So the train will send data
readily to cloud storage.
Also, the train should
be equipped with 5G.
And the reason for
that is because imagine
that the train, for
whatever reason,
is stopped in the
middle of the train.
So we should be able to send
information very quickly
to a facility for processing.
So 5G should operate
also as well with Wi-Fi.
And the amount of information
we're going to send
are not only the
SQLite databases,
but also the
multimedia files are
going to be sent to
the cloud storage.
So the rest will be
more or less the same.
Cloud Function--
a Cloud Function
here will trigger a function
that will start a Dataflow
pipeline in order to collect
all the information that
will be sent to BigQuery
for visualization,
and potentially to
Cloud Machine Learning
to train a new model we require.
And the second-- so to
summarize, so Wi-Fi or 5G data
is going to be sent
to cloud storage
and then to Cloud Functions
for extracting the information
to cloud storage,
and then processing
and the Dataflow and
machine learning,
and finally to visualize.
And the architecture related to
real-time processing and event
data management are going merge.
So the two previous one are
going to merge into just one.
And in this particular
case, we are
going to use MQTT and also the
batch information for events
and alarms.
And this time, we are going
to use Dataflow in order
to unify the processing
of real time and batch,
the operation where we
unify both architectures.
So, all the data will go
to Cloud IoT Core, then
a Cloud Function.
So, we'll create a
function in order
to be processed by Pub/Sub and
go to Dataflow and AppEngine.
I would like to
highlight something
about this architecture, which
is the serverless approach,
and especially the
usage of Dataflow
here for processing
all the information.
This is very
interesting for Talgo
because Dataflow allows
scaling up and scaling down.
So during the day,
trains are operating.
And you need to process
a lot of information.
Dataflow can scale up in order
to process more information
if required.
But during the night when
trains do not operate,
basically Dataflow
can scale down
and Talgo is going to pay
nothing for processing, OK?
Because Dataflow
allows scaling up
and scaling down automatically.
So that means that
during the day
while the trains are operating
between the different lines,
trains are going
to send information
and Dataflow is
going to scale up.
But during the night when
trains are not operating,
Dataflow is going to
automatically scale down
and Talgo will not pay
anything for the Dataflow
or for Cloud IoT Core
or for Cloud Pub/Sub.
So this is the advantage
of a serverless approach.
This is an advantage of
a serverless architecture
like this, OK?
So all this solution is going
to scale up and scale down
automatically.
And I make a remark on the
scaling down automatically.
I mean, Talgo is not going to
do anything during the night
in order to switch
off the machines
or switch off the workers
in order to pay less.
So this is going to be done
automatically by Google Cloud.
Another advantage like
this is that the Dataflow
is going to unify the processing
model of batch and streaming.
So actually, the
same probe is going
to make both type
of processing, OK?
Batch for events and
alarms, and processing
for real-time information.
So to summarize
this architecture,
so we are going to send
information in batches
and then streaming
into the cloud.
That will go to-- some
of them to the IoT Core.
And then Dataflow will provide
the serverless approach
with an automatically
scaling up and scaling down
whenever it is required, and
the data stored on AppEngine
for visualization
So in this architecture,
we have machine learning.
And actually Talgo
is working today
on some machine learning models
that Jose Antonio's going
to explain in a second that are
actually being worked today.
So, now I'm going to pass
the word to Jose Antonio
because he's going to
explain us a machine learning
predictive maintenance case
which we are using today
in the Saudi Arabia line.
JOSE ANTONIO MARCOS
ALBERCA: Thank you, Rafael.
OK, now I'm going to talk about
the Talgo Tesla application.
This application
has been developed
using machine
learning to predict
the failures of different
system of the train in advance.
As an example, I'm
going to explain you
how the application
is capable to predict
the failures of
the axle bearings
in advance at least three weeks.
OK, it works in this way.
The axle of the
train you can see
in the top part of the
screen has four bearings.
Each bearing has a
temperature sensor.
Every temperature sensor is
being monitored in real time.
So the neural network, using
Keras library and TensorFlow
backend, predict the
temperature for its sensor
every second using the other
three real-time temperatures,
or the other three sensors
plus the outside temperature.
Once the temperature
is predicted,
the application is
comparing this temperature
with the real one.
If the difference between
them is higher than expected,
the application
provides an alarm.
And also the most
important thing
is that we are able to
predict the failure in advance
at least three weeks
in order to avoid
to have some failure in the
train during the service
and to do the maintenance
as preventive maintenance.
OK, in this screen, you
can see in the upper part
the general overview of
the train with the axles.
For example, this axle,
this bearing, has an alarm.
That means that this difference
between the real temperature,
which is the blue,
with the calculated one
is higher than the limit.
So the application gets an alarm
to be fixed for the maintenance
people and for the engineers.
And now we are going to see a
video with all the information
that I present before.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So, we are performing
real-time monitoring
in very extreme conditions,
weather conditions, Kazakhstan,
or in the middle of the
desert, Saudi Arabia.
We are sending the
data from the center
of the train to the cloud.
We are streaming 2,000
signals per second
from different trains, different
countries, to the cloud.
So once we have
the data there, we
are able to analyze the
data with our expertise.
And we can get
insight from the data
in order to improve the
safety, the reliability
and the availability
of the train.
Unlike in F1, we have to perform
the maintenance as needed,
using machine learning
and real-time monitoring
to improve the safety,
reliability, and maintenance.
[END PLAYBACK]
And now, what's next?
To connect not only
the train, but also
all the assets that
Talgo has in a global IoT
platform using our application
Talgo Tesla and Google
Cloud solution.
For example, we are developing
a new equipment called TALVI,
capable to inspect the
train automatically
when the train is running
up to 100 miles per hour
on the track.
This equipment has
3D scan technology
and visual artificial cameras
to inspect the wheel parameters,
the side integrity of the train,
the brakes, the frame, and also
the roof inspections.
So all this we are able to
do thanks to the IoT Cloud
platform.
So that's all.
Thank you.
And I hope that it has
been interesting for you
and useful maybe for
your business case.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]